So, probably the last place that you think
about hope and optimism existing is in prison,
but in the last ten years of working there
I've come to realize that all humans possess
these things—they just need a little coaxing
sometimes.
In June 2006 The Actors' Gang Theater Company
started an experiment: we decided to take
the Sunday night workshop we do with our whole
company into prison to work with non-actors,
to see what kind of effect our style of theater
would have on them.
So the style of theater we work in is a really
bastardized version of the Italian tradition
of Commedia Dell’Arte.
It's masks, white-face, high emotional, physical
work, so we call it the “style.”
We took that workshop program into prison
and were absolutely astounded by the effect
it had on these non-actors and how it started
to help them be able to heal their trauma.
We've seen this approach transform prison
yards, we've seen it break down barriers of
race and separation, and that has happened
through the courage of these people, picking
up the tools that we've offered them and using
those tools to transform their emotional lives,
and they found a safe space in our work to
be able to do that.
And as a result we have a ten percent recidivism
rate and an 89 percent drop in in-prison infractions
because these people now know how to deal
with their emotions.
So amazingly, this little engine that could,
after ten years is now in ten prisons across
California, and for me the thing that makes
me so proud is that any day of the week there
will be a student-led program happening in
a prison.
Like right now, there's a program happening
in the prison that's led by our students,
and we go and check in and support them every
six weeks.
Apart from the reentry programs that we have,
which is now run by one of our former students—we
employed him the day he paroled, to run that
reentry program—we are also creating a program
for correctional officers, who are often as
traumatized as the people that they are overseeing.
It's the highest suicide rate of any job.
The real secret of this work, for those of
us who are lucky enough to do it, is that
we get as much, if not more, from the experience.
One of our juvie girls told me the other day,
when people come and work with us she always
thinks to herself, “Take off your cape,”
and this has become out motto now.
Take off your cape, because we're not in the
business of saving people.
We're going in and offering them tools that
we know work and as a result changing our
own lives.
I've definitely become a better person and
a better actor, and these people have literally
changed my life.
So I'm really honored to introduce the stars
of this work: the people.
I mean it was an idea, right?
I had an idea ten years ago; a lot of people
have ideas.
It doesn't really mean anything unless people
make it happen, and these are the people that
made that happen.
So I'd like to start off by introducing Chris
Bingley.
Chris Bingley: Hello.
Good afternoon everyone.
I'm Chris Bingley.
As Sabra said I returned to the community
last Friday from a 12-year prison sentence.
Most of my time—honestly there's not a whole
lot of programs inside of California prisons—so
I just kind of sat around and kind of read
books and tried to better myself on my own.
But towards the end of my sentence—I think
I've been doing The Actors' Gang for about
five years—the Prison Project came in and
it gave me a lot of tools.
It gave me a lot of tools to deal with prison,
to deal with myself, and now that I'm out
here it's given me a lot of tools that I'm
using out here as well.
I'm using those tools with my family, at my
job, just everywhere I go.
So just to explain what got me into prison
is pretty much not knowing how to manage my
own emotions.
I was angry growing up and I kept a lot of
that stuff inside of me, and I found people
that were angry just like I was, and we did
angry things and that's what led me to prison.
Getting involved in with work it helped me
to be able to express my emotions, something
that I was never taught to do.
I just, like I said, kept everything inside
of me, so what this work did is it created
a safe place for me to be able to express
myself no matter what, without judgment, whether
it be happy, sad, angry or fear, because are
the four emotions that we deal with.
And it gave me a chance to exorcise those
emotions that were inside of me that I was
so used to just constantly pushing down and
that I was used to just acting out.
So this work gave me a lot of tools to learn
how to manage my emotions.
Not only that but all kinds of stuff, from
becoming a team player to supporting—we
always say in The Actors' Gang, “Support
your brother, or support the other actor that's
onstage with you.”
Before being involved in this kind of work
I was kind of like a selfish person, just
all by myself, so it just taught me to be
more human, to be able to look in another
person's eyes and express an emotion, you
know, and be able to identify with the next
person.
So this work is great and I know it's doing
a lot for people inside.
As Sabra said it's breaking down a lot of
barriers.
People that would normally want to fight each
other and want to stab each other, they're
friends in there because this work, it builds
a bridge between different races, between
different gangs, all that stuff, and we can
relate to each other because of this work.